oggi parleremo di come per poter
per un futuro più verde sia più
sostenibile
possiamo creare un mondo più bianco
un po come in queste immagini dove
vediamo uno spazio naturale che appare
più bianco rispetto al normale
sembra quasi paradossale ma in realtà
vedremo oggi come cambiando il colore
delle superfici possiamo in qualche modo
contribuire alla mitigazione del
cambiamento climatico
infatti oggi non è più in discussione se
c'è un un cambiamento climatico
ma come possiamo in qualche modo
rallentare il cambiamento in atto in
particolar modo come possiamo mantenere
l'aumento della temperatura globale
entro i 2 gradi centigradi secondo
quanto previsto dagli accordi di parigi
a tale scopo esistono diversi approcci
che possono essere utilizzati quello
sicuramente più efficace è rappresentato
dalla modificazione delle nostre
abitudini di vita nella riduzione
nell'utilizzo dei combustibili fossili o
nell'aumento dell'efficienza dei nostri
processi industriali ma allo stesso modo
noi possiamo anche contribuire
attraverso la cattura e lo stoccaggio
dell'anidride carbonica nel suolo oppure
possiamo procedere alla sostituzione
delle energie fossili con energie
rinnovabili in particolar modo per
catturare e stoccare la co2
tutti sanno che il cambiamento d'uso del
suolo in particolar modo l'espansione
delle foreste può in qualche modo
aumentare la quantità di co2 fissata
negli ecosistemi infatti annualmente una
foresta è in grado di stoccare in media
circa 6 tonnellate di co2 all'anno a
ettaro e di emettere più di 4 tonnellate
di ossigeno all'anno questo corrisponde
a circa le missioni di due automobili
che fanno 20 mila chilometri all'anno ma
quindi quanto possono contribuire i
boschi della nostra regione
a fissare la co2 è fondamentalmente i
316 mila ettari di foreste friulane
possono bilanciare circa
per cento del parco macchine della
nostra regione ma solo il 9,5 per cento
delle emissioni totali
appare quindi evidente che dobbiamo
mettere in campo altre soluzioni per
cercare di mitigare il cambiamento
climatico per cui ritornando al tema
della di oggi quindi un per un futuro
più verde un mondo più bianco partiamo
dalla teoria proprio di gaia ossia che
gli organismi e le loro interazioni
possono modificare in qualche modo
l'ambiente rendendolo favorevole alla
loro sopravvivenza
in questo si innesta la teoria di lave
l'ok delle margherite bianche ossia
modificando la proporzione tra
margherite bianche margheri tenere in un
pianeta ideale questo può andare a
modificare la temperatura e quindi
favorire la sopravvivenza di queste due
specie in pratica la teoria si basa sul
concetto di albedo sia sulla quantità di
radiazione che una superficie riflette
rispetto a quanto arriva una superficie
bianca come può essere la neve è
caratterizzata donna ed elevata
riflettività quindi da un elevato albedo
una superficie invece scura una
superficie nera è caratterizzata da una
bassa riflettività quindi nel caso in
cui la riflettività sia alta la
radiazione viene riflessa negli strati
alti dell'atmosfera e pertanto non
contribuisce al riscaldamento globale al
contrario se viene invece assorbita dal
corpo viene successivamente riemessa
come radiazione termica e quindi aumenta
la temperatura globale per aumentare
quindi l'albedo del nostro pianeta sono
state proposte molte soluzioni alcune
anche abbastanza fantasiose come per
esempio degli specchi solari da
collocare nello spazio proprio per
riflettere maggiormente la radiazione o
aumentare lario sul presente in
atmosfera ma ci concentreremo oggi
soprattutto su ciò che può avvenire a
livello della superficie proprio
terrestre ossia su quelli che sono i
cambiamenti di albedo delle superfici
agricole e forestali
e noto quindi come nel momento in cui
noi abbiamo un certo paesaggio agricolo
la il colore delle diverse superfici e
viste da satellite ci appare molto
diverso in particolar modo le superfici
forestali ci appaiono più scure rispetto
per esempio alle superfici agricole
questo è il motivo per cui recentemente
alcuni studi hanno calcolato che le
piantagioni forestali è vero che fissano
carbonio atmosferico attraverso la
fotosintesi
ma questo effetto è completamente
bilanciato dal fatto che essendo più
scure contribuiscono maggiormente al
riscaldamento globale ma al contrario
noi potremmo immaginare in qualche modo
di manipolare il colore delle superfici
agricole e forestali e quindi per
esempio aumentare quello che è l'albedo
ma come possiamo fare ciò
fondamentalmente possiamo per esempio
colorare le superfici aggiungendo degli
inerti altamente riflettenti come per
esempio il caolino in questa foto
vediamo un prato normale ed un prato
colorato di bianco attraverso il caolino
si vede bene come l'aumento dell'albedo
è estremamente significativo ma altre
strategie che possono essere utilizzate
sono per esempio quello di utilizzare
delle coltivazioni di copertura durante
il periodo invernale oppure lasciare i
residui agricoli sulla superficie del
suolo in maniera tale da renderlo più
chiaro
sempre nei periodi invernali ma un'altra
strategia quella forse più interessante
è rappresentata dalla possibilità di
utilizzare dei mutanti naturali di
specie agricole e forestali comunemente
coltivate in questo caso questo i
mutanti sono caratterizzati da una minor
produzione di clorofilla livello
fogliare quindi invece che apparirci
verdi ci appaiono di colore bianco
quindi sono caratterizzati da una
maggiore riflettività esistono i mutanti
in campo agricolo qui in questa prima
fotografia vediamo per esempio una soia
ma esistono anche mutanti in campo
forestale e quindi potenzialmente
i disabili in piantagioni per la
produzione delle biomasse come nel caso
della robinia oppure nel caso del pioppo
o ancora nel caso del del salice
in questo senso quindi abbiamo provato a
sperimentare alcuni di questi mutanti
per provare a verificare la loro
efficacia nella mitigazione del
cambiamento climatico
in questa foto vediamo appunto un campo
sperimentale nell'azienda agraria
dell'università dove le due varietà sono
messe a confronto le due varietà come
detto sono caratterizzate da una forte
differenza nel contenuto di clorofilla e
quindi la varietà più chiara è
caratterizzata da un maggiore albedo
durante tutta la stagione vegetativa e
durante tutte le ore del giorno
questo quindi si traduce in una
variazione complessiva di albedo media
del 14 per cento e quindi in un forte
effetto sul potenziale riscaldamento
globale
immaginando di coltivare tutta la tutti
i campi di soia a livello globale con
una soglia cloro phil deficit quindi con
minor clorofilla abbiamo stimato che si
potrebbero risparmiare circa 4,4 giga
tonnellate di co2
tuttavia per proporre una soluzione del
genere al contadino
dobbiamo essere sicuri che le due
varietà producano praticamente uguali in
questo senso le misure che abbiamo fatto
a livello fogliare dimostrano come
l'attività fotosintetica tra le due
varietà sia praticamente identica allo
stesso modo utilizzando delle camere
chiuse abbiamo misurato lo scambio
gassoso a livello di intera copertura e
anche in questo caso la fotosintesi e
stata la stessa tuttavia nel momento in
cui andiamo a raccogliere vediamo che
c'è una differenza di quasi il 20 per
cento nella produzione complessiva
diverse sono le ipotesi su cui ci stiamo
muovendo per chiarire questo aspetto ma
soprattutto per individuare delle
varietà che pur avendo un contenuto di
clorofilla minore possano garantire
comunque una maggiore o uguale
produzione rispetto alle varietà
commerciali
proprio perché questo ci garantirebbe di
poter adottare una strategia vincente
sia dal punto di vista della produzione
agricole ma soprattutto dal punto di
vista della mitigazione del cambiamento
climatico
grazie